kesha i have to get your reaction to
something right off the bat right away
did you see that you were trending on
twitter yesterday
no okay so no what there was
there was a video going viral of an
altercation like at a department store
over wearing a mask or not
and you can hear your song take it off
playing in the background like at the
store
keep it on everybody keep poor mask on
you heard her from kesha herself okay
keep your mask up but
how has quarantine or life
been for you these days um it's been
very bizarre i have to say it's the most
still and like
quiet that my life has ever been in my
entire life
and which is really uncomfortable and
also
very introspective the past like 12
months have been
just like you know it's been weird i
don't think anybody can argue that it's
been weird
so what would you say has been like the
biggest thing you learned about yourself
during this time
i think that i learned how to be by
myself
for the first time ever in my life
because i went from
being at home and then i moved to la and
i was just like
crazy and around a bunch of people all
the time and then i went on tour
for you know almost 10 years tick tock
came out
10 we got almost 11 years wow
wake up in the morning feeling like pda
i was just so used to you know getting
ready and there'd be 10 people around
and we'd all be talking and i
like never was alone so
see i believe that you're actually more
intuitive than you're giving yourself
credit i mean you created a song called
tick tock before it was a thing
before tick tock was the thing that
we're all doing ourselves during
quarantine so
i i like summoned that from the universe
[Music]
let's talk about your podcast kesha and
the creepies i'm really into
spiritual things and like the
supernatural and i'm just like
i would call myself a
what's the word like i'm a spiritual
explorer and i'm doing on my podcast is
i'm just talking about anything
supernatural anything unexplainable i'm
talking to musicians about the craziest
stuff they've ever gone through all
different kinds of people from all over
the world and
giving their wildest experiences
and it's just like helping my
perspective grow just
seeing world and spirituality and the
supernatural from everybody's
different perspective it's been so
interesting for me because i've always
been into it what would you say is like
the
coolest or biggest thing you learn from
these conversations
um with demi lovato i love the
conversation we had
because she just turned me on to like a
whole
new there are a couple books she
mentioned and an app she mentioned that
i
immediately downloaded and i made my
family for christmas all i want for
christmas is
us all to meditate and try to channel
extraterrestrials and they're like okay
so i'm like trying to get all my
friends and family into meditating the
aliens to us my new hobby
because of demi lovato something in that
thank you jenny for that it's fun and we
[ __ ] about crazy poor experiences
with alice cooper but then we also talk
about
you know our own spirituality between
me and so many different kinds of people
and i'm
speaking to a wizard i feel like that's
when what is that next week
okay beginning of february you're going
to hear one wizard like the real wizard
who made unicorns in the 80s
come on come on has it been helpful for
you
in your life especially during this time
to kind of like refocus the energy
into something like this podcast yes i
love making music and i love my fans but
i also feel like on
my spiritual and personal growth side i
want to take them with me on
that journey because it's been really
influencing the music i'm making
and i just i want to be as connected to
everyone and grow as much as
humanly possible because i think it's
necessary we need to grow we need to
grow and
go together and i just want to find
common ground and
just have conversations with people i
think
fighting and yelling i feel like
conversations be a
nicer way to deal with for sure
you want to relate to people on a human
level not as
musicians not as artists not as
celebrities but as humans i get that
and not as like a democrat or a
republican right
i just want to talk to people because i
think if we all kind of
put our egos aside we're all human
beings and i think
if you actually speak to people you can
just understand them
more and i just want to understand
people and what makes people
angry and what makes people feel alive
and what makes people happy makes people
sad
what they believe in and i just want to
i want to take my fans on that journey
with me because it's
something i always share everything with
my hands i love them and i do
i do miss touring i necessarily miss
putting on like four layers of spanx and
type like that glitter
the glitter the rainbows yeah the
glitter right the glitter
i put that on while i walk around my
house
like that apologies of course you really
do have a very special relationship
with your fans unlike you know a few pop
stars out there what does their support
mean to you in every project that you do
i always want to give my fans a place
where they can come feel
safe they can come be themselves and
they do not feel
judged because i've always wanted that
place and i realized looking back over
my life
i never really felt like i had that
except for when i went to see live music
so i feel like my duty
and it's my life goal to make a place
where people can come
and feel like they can completely be
themselves and do whatever they want and
be
be themselves fully and like not be
judged
and just be accepted and have a
beautiful wonderful experience
and i don't know i just love
facilitating a place for people to be
happy someone has been to one of your
shows i went to your last tour that's
exactly
the world you create that and glitter
bombs galore everywhere you walk out
still dancing with a big smile on your
face why
well i think everything is more fun if
you put glitter on top of this
hey bed working on some of my own
special magical extra magical glitter
on casserole so just like look at that
look out for that
i was gonna say it's already shining
shimmering and splendid over at kesher
rose beauty so now you're doing some
more
some more glitter i think i need to get
more aggressively into
glitter because ham the um
the glitter queen sorcerer switch
and i feel like i'm really putting all
my energy into finding like
magical glitter that everyone can stick
all over their face and body
the world could use a little more
glitter from kesha so sprinkle that
everywhere always more glitter yeah
it fixes a lot of things uh what do you
want your fans to know about
the music you are working on and the
story you're trying to tell next
i've been working on music that i'm
really
really excited about and it's just
different to anything
i've ever put out and it's a
culmination of all the kinds of music i
like but it's also
the most introspective and also
inspired by the world that i've ever
felt because i'm just
sitting and listening and
i just feel like i have so much to learn
i'm very humbled by
the past year and i can't wait for
you guys to hear it i'm really excited
about it but i'm like
i'm a little bit of like a like a
perfectionist when it comes to making my
music
perfectly imperfect so i'm like finding
video
have you found that you want or are
working with other people on this
project like do you have any like
collabs lined up for this i can't tell
you i
literally am giving this okay symbol i
have a thing coming
and that's all i got
you have like a timeline do you have an
idea of when you want to drop the next
single
hopefully soon i've been working on a
song that
is hopefully going to bring people a
little bit
of joy in this really bizarre
insane very intense confusing
time um i always try to
be hopeful so i'll leave it at that
before we go we want to take a look back
way back
at an appearance you had on the simple
live because fans have been begging
for a reboot
oh that's when i had orange in here hi
sexy his name is rob
are you a cowboy no i'm an investment
banker actually
do you like to dance so if this was your
mom now i'm gonna vomit
thank you for embarrassing me
like do you even know and remember that
kesha that version
oh yeah that was like i remember when
they came to stay at my mom's house that
she still lives in that house and i
remember they ended up hooking her up
with a guy
on that show that a week later i went
out to
the gay bar and i saw him like out dance
and i was like you went on a date with
my mom and
that is some tea i am so shook over that
that's hilarious
i can't believe that well fans are
asking for a reboot of the simple life
would you like to see it come back
if they want it i don't know if i
can export that um that look
ever i don't think that looks ever going
to be what i revisit
but that looks haunts me that it lives
on the internet but we should do a
simple life with you
the lead i i feel like
i don't even know what that means what
do you do you roam around and uh
work at different kinds of jobs i think
they would just put you in experiences
you've never been in
you know what i mean in cities you've
never been in
not at all that's true you have done it
all on that note
i mean music a cosmetics line your
podcast what's left on the kesha bucket
list
i mean
i don't know that's a good question i
like i have a couple things
that i like wanna do i really wanna um
become a scuba dive instructor one day
you are into the
water uh sports right now you just went
paddle boarding
i love it i'm obsessed with animals and
like
i have like a bunch of whale tattoos and
stuff so i'm like
really obsessed with animals and just
spending as much time as possible with
animals so
anything that can get me in the water
with an animal i'm game for